Here's our overall strategy.
We're going to take a CNF formula f, and
turn it into a 3 cnf formula f prime,
which will include some additional
variables, which we'll label y.
And this formula f prime will
have the property, that, for
any truth assignment t for f.
T will satisfy f.
If and only if there exists a way
of extending t, we'll call this ty,
over the variables Y,
such that t extended by ty
satisfies the new clause f prime.
Let's illustrate such a mapping for
a simple example.
Take this disjunction of four literals.
Note that the zi are literals here,
so they could be x1, x1 bar, etc.
Remember that disjunction
means logical or, so
this whole clause is true if
any one of the literals is.
We will map this clause of size
four into two clauses of size three
by introducing a new variable y,
like so.
Let's confirm that this property holds.
If the original clause is true
under some truth assignment,
then we can set y to be Z1 or Z2.
This clause will be satisfied
by one of the Zs and
this one will be satisfied by Y.
Going the other direction,
suppose that we have a truth assignment
that satisfies both of these clauses.
On the one hand, Y might be true.
But that then implies that Z1 or Z2 is
true, and so this clause must be true.
On the other hand, Y might be false,
but that then implies that Z3 or
Z4 is true, and hence this original
clause would be true as well.
If you've understood this,
then you've understood the crux
of why this reduction works.
More details to come.